[Musique]
au coeur de paris dans le 20ème
arrondissement le quartier de sharon a
conservé son aspect de village la rue
saint blaise la place des grès la rue
des balkans autant de rues pavées sur
lesquels s'ouvrent des maisons rurales
du xviie et du xviiie siècle quand
sharon était à la campagne sharon est le
dernier exemple à paris de ce type de
maison les autres ont été détruites au
siècle dernier
ici je suis tellement habitué je tiens
plus mon mari aussi moment ils sont 60
ans qu'il est là aussi on tient pas du
tout été le cas vous avez l'impression
d'être dans paris non c'est dans un
village parce qu'on est tous soudés
ancien tout mais c'est beaucoup comme à
tous les anciens australienne et comme
il fallait aussi plaît beaucoup mais je
vois bien que rester l'appartement
commodités ces vieux ça serait bien soit
besoin d'être un peu arrangé restauré il
nous fait quand même aussi paix qu'on
est là le site qu'est ce que c'est cette
église qui est coiffé qui coiffe pardon
cette éminence avec se paieront qui
accèdent et qui conduit l'homme et en
même temps c'est de marquer au cours des
siècles ont commencé depuis que cette
église a été construite à partir du
cadre du 11e siècle
ces demeures qui se sont fixés contre
elle un peu comme des huîtres sur un
rocher ou des brebis autour de son
pasteur et bien se sont agglomérés et
c'est ce qui donne véritablement avec
cette voix sainte si j'ose dire avec
cette artère centrale de village cela
donne en fait
et bien cet ensemble admirable cependant
le village de sharon perd peu à peu de
son âme depuis plusieurs années ses
habitants voit s'élever d'immenses
immeubles autour d'eux certains désertes
et les maisons restent à l'abandon les
autres les fidèles lutte pour préserver
les derniers îlots de leur quartier car
si l'église de sharon et protéger ainsi
qu'un petit périmètre autour d'elle
c'est tout le site que les habitants
veulent conserver et restaurer
la crainte s'exprime d'une part par
l'environnement effectivement il y a
d'abord tout c'est tours qui tel un
nouveau chicago en serre ce petit
village dans une taille de faire dans
une taille de mort de béton et il y a
également le fait que si l'on se réfère
à l'arrêté préfectoral du mois de
février 1970 et bien toute cette partie
de du coeur de sharon toute cette partie
de sharon sera bel et bien détruites
ceci l'a été explicitement indiqué dans
cet arrêté préfectoral et il ne faut pas
oublier que si personne ne s'émeut de la
grande concentration de richesses rural
et architectural qui sont renfermés
eh bien on peut dire que bel et bien
l'année prochaine au mois d'octobre 1975
toute expropriation devra être effectuée
non seulement mais également terminé et
qu'il faudra détruire sur avis du
secrétaire d'état à la culture un arrêté
récent a prévu d'accroître les
dimensions du site protégé cela devrait
sauver bien sûr le village de sharon est
une partie du patrimoine parisien
[Musique]